I think that there will always be small
scale scandals.
There were always be plagiarist.
There will always be people who didn't
make the phone calls that they claim to
be made.
But the chronic repeated abuse that
Jason Blair was engaged,
and I don't think it happened at a
newspaper that has a public editor or an
ombudsman.
Um,
yes,
there was a phone number published in
the newspaper in The Times every day for
people to call if they had something
that they objected to.
And when I got there I thought I'd try
out the system.
Well,
it's a mailbox full.
Nobody had been paying attention to it.
If you have somebody whose job is
specifically to respond to readers who
are complaining or who are pointing out
error or pointing out misbehavior on the
part of reporters,
it's very hard.
I can't imagine that it would not be
caught after the second or third time
because you know,
somebody reading that mail,
somebody is paying attention to it.
My biggest concern about the digital
technology as it's coming to the
newsreel is anonymity of writers.
Um,
whether that's the person who's writing
a blog or who's commenting,
uh,
on,
on a sign on assigned blog,
uh,
we don't know who those people are.
And,
um,
one thing,
and this is not an ethical issue,
this is a question of stability and
taste.
I mean,
it allows cowards to hide,
uh,
behind,
um,
that,
that scrim while they have the freedom
to say really awful and disgusting
things and I can't stand that.
It's very upsetting to me.
Uh,
but beyond that,
there have been a few instances where
that person who's been commenting on
this website or that website in fact as
a principal in the story,
uh,
is in fact a,
a figure who has a self interest.
But as hiding that self interest,
uh,
I would really be delighted to see the,
the websites of the world just suddenly
declare,
put on your real name or we don't care
what you have to say.
And in fact,
I don't care what you or you shouldn't
care what I have to say if I'm not
willing to put my name behind it.
I think that the,
the,
the peak years for,
for quality journalism in this country,
1970s and early 1980s,
uh,
if you go back before then,
I mean,
pick up a copy of the New York Times in
1965 Sunday,
it was unbelievably dull.
It was officially is if the PR,
there were a new Peruvian ambassador
appointed there.
It was in the paper.
Uh,
the shipping news that just the,
the sort of,
the kind of the deadly,
uh,
um,
required drone,
uh,
of news in those days was,
was really pretty awful.
The paper got much,
much better after that as an all
American journalism.
And I think the Watergate obviously had
a great deal to do with Watergate and
also the magazine writers of the 60s,
uh,
people like,
like gay Talese and David Halberstam who
move both came out of the Times but then
moved to other arenas to be able to do
more than simply chronicle.
They could write.
They did more of that coming together.
That,
and the great victory for journalism
that was Watergate,
uh,
created a,
I think in the 70s that attracted better
people to the industry.
It was a more exciting thing to do.
And they,
and people did their greatest work then,
and the standards were very,
very high.
Uh,
as we get into the 90s,
and we began to have an economic trouble
beginning to show up,
you know,
a Time magazine where I worked for quite
a while in 1990,
90 had eight full time critics on staff
doing different things.
Uh,
today I think there's one full time
critic,
and that's,
uh,
not the criticism is the most important
thing in the world,
but I use it as an indication of how
things have shrunk back because of the
economic problems.